the concept of space is familiar to all
of us
generally speaking the knowledge of the
average person
is limited to some basic facts about our
system and the universe around it
but the most exciting things on the
cosmos take place in remote
areas not readily available to our eyes
and if we look beyond the boundaries of
the solar system
a fascinating picture of infinite space
opens up to us
today i invite you on a journey to those
mysterious places realistically quite
beyond our physical reach
and as we get further away from our
earth we will be braving the most
forbidding
areas of space our flight starts in the
vicinity of titan
then we will move on to the most
dangerous asteroids
and a bit later take a look at pluto
right after that we will set out to
observe some potentially habitable
exoplanets
check out the micro quasar ss433
and then see what intergalactic space
looks like
as our journey draws to an end we will
consider the future of our universe
and try to predict what will happen
after its demise
i hope you have fastened your seat belts
let's get going
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
apart from the earth titan is the only
celestial body in the solar system with
liquid on its surface
unlike our earth however this liquid
isn't water
but a mixture of liquid hydrocarbons for
the most part
methane and ethane oceans on titan were
first
seen in radar images which were beamed
back by the cassini probe on the 21st of
july 2006.
in the period from 2004 to 2017
the space probe approached titan on 127
occasions
thanks to these photos scientists were
able to successfully map out
the entire surface of this moon in fine
detail
analysis of the relief and its features
revealed that the same processes were
instrumental in its formation
both on titans and the earth's surfaces
the only difference lies in the fact
that water was the main factor for
relief formation on our earth
whereas on titan it was liquid
hydrocarbons
as a result titan's surface is also
covered by lakes
seas rivers and bays just like that of
our planet
it also rains there on a regular basis
too
titans lakes of the most part rather
vast
but not really deep their number
reaching 650
the biggest of them are referred to as
seas or mares and they have been dubbed
after mythical sea creatures
kraken mare lygia mre and pangamare
there are dunes on titan's equator which
is explained by the fact that the
climate in that area is the driest
these areas account for 17 percent of
the overall surface of this moon
with mountains and labyrinths making up
and one and a half percent respectively
most of titan's surface
or 65 percent to be precise is covered
by planes
as for mountain ridges they stretch for
several dozens of kilometers
with a height reaching several
kilometers
only 23 impact craters have been
discovered on titan
their diameter over 20 kilometers which
is not more than 0.4 percent of the
total area
most craters are believed to have
disappeared due to highly intensive
erosion processes
that have been taking place for several
hundred million years
due to some organic compounds which
include atoms of nitrogen
titan and its atmosphere are of an
orange hue
now let's talk about big liquid objects
on titan
the area of kraken mare the largest one
discovered on its surface
is approximately 400 000 square
kilometers
and its length measures about 1100
kilometers located in the satellite's
northern hemisphere
this body of liquid is estimated to be
up to 200 meters deep
the second largest body of liquid on
titan like
mra is also situated in the northern
hemisphere
with its width measuring about 500
kilometers and its depth reaching up to
170 meters
lygia mre covers an area of
approximately a hundred thousand square
kilometers the third and the smallest
sea on titan
pangamare is also the most northern of
the three
its diameter measures approximately 380
kilometers
these seas are most likely to be made up
of liquid methane and ethane
as both gases are rather abundant in
titan's atmosphere
regularly forming dense clouds
it must be due to evaporation of methane
and ethane from the surfaces of these
maoris that these gases can be found in
the satellite's atmosphere
there are some dark spots to be seen in
images of titan's surface
they are likely to be drifting chunks of
ice that have emerged from the bottom
as a rule this kind of hydrocarbon ice
floats in temperatures close to 183
degrees celsius below zero
if the temperature drops still lower
nitrogen bubbles in the ice rocks will
account for less than five percent
which makes these rocks sink it is also
highly probable that in some areas of
titan there may be an ice shield
enveloping liquid methane both below and
above
it's worth mentioning that the chemical
composition of the liquid on titan
is different depending on an area since
it is liquid gases with different
boiling points that account for most of
the liquid on titan
the chemical composition largely depends
on temperature
for example the chemical composition of
the liquid at the pearls is different
from that at the equator
which is warmer apart from bodies of
liquid on the surface
there may also be a subsurface ocean of
impressive proportions on titan
and for all we know it may contain water
this hypothesis was put forward as an
inference from this idea
following saturn's tidal effects the
core may get heated up
and a high enough temperature may be
sustained for liquid water to be formed
under titan's surface
besides cassini's images from 2005 and
2007 revealed that some features of
relief had shifted approximately 30
kilometers
since titan is tidally locked to saturn
that is it faces it with the same side
at all times
this shift may be accounted for by the
fact that titan's ice shell is separated
from the main body by a global liquid
layer
the subsurface water is thought to
contain a considerable amount of
ammonium which acts as an anti-freezing
substance
thus decreasing the water's critical
freezing point
coupled with a high pressure from
titan's crust this may be an additional
favorable condition for the subsurface
ocean
this ocean may well lie as deep as
approximately 100 kilometers
with its water rich in various sorts
this liquid
is most likely to be a mixture of salts
and its chemical composition
includes salts containing sodium
potassium and sulfur
the depth of the ocean is different
depending on the area of titan
with liquid freezing and forming an ice
crust in certain areas
the exceptionally high sword
concentration makes it too harsh an
environment to support
any life as for titan's land
there is a chance of encountering simple
life forms on its surface
titan's atmosphere is rather dense and
chemically active
containing diverse organic compounds
this allows us to assume that there may
be life in the atmosphere's upper layers
it seems feasible that simple organisms
could be sustained by gas hydrogen
and also consume molecules of acetylene
after digesting these in return they
could produce
methane it should be mentioned that
relatively recently
highly active organic molecules were
discovered in titan's atmosphere
the substance in question is called
cyclopropanilidine
this is an unstable and highly active
material which cannot be observed on
earth
anywhere but in a laboratory environment
scientists first came
across it in 1985 and clouds of
interstellar gas in space
cyclopropanilidine is crucial in forming
larger organic molecules
its discovery on titan was the first
case of finding it in the atmosphere of
a planet rather than an interstellar
environment
this discovery will certainly help
scientists to see titan's chemical
evolution from a different angle
there are also some alternative theories
about life on this satellite
according to these there could also be
life forms in liquid methane rivers
but this is feasible only on condition
that these organisms live on hydrogen
rather than oxygen
and produce methane rather than carbon
dioxide
unlike organisms on our earth however
since titan does not lie in the
goldilocks zone and its surface
temperature is as low as about 180
degrees below
zero these hypothetical organisms would
differ a lot from those we used to see
on our planet lipid cell membranes for
instance
which are typical earth dwellers
wouldn't be able to survive in such
conditions
some really bizarre analogues would then
be produced by evolution processes
and we can't venture even a wild guess
as to what they would be like
be it as it may climatic conditions on
titan really are
able to sustain certain forms of
microbial life
this is the main object of interest for
nasa's dragonfly spacecraft planned to
be launched to titan in 2027 to
investigate
and who knows perhaps this mission is
destined to reveal
something even more fascinating than
we've already found out
the search for alien life forms is
undoubtedly an arduous task
that will probably not yield any results
until the next millennium
but its global significance can hardly
be overestimated
if at some point we succeed in our
attempts
this will be a major milestone and the
beginning of a new era in the history of
mankind
it will not only allow humans to enhance
their own knowledge
but also begin a long and scrupulous
process of fostering relationships
with intelligent beings from another
world
large objects do approach our planets
now and then
for example on the 14th of november 2020
asteroid 2020 vt4 with a diameter
measuring about 10 meters past our earth
at a distance of 383
kilometers from the surface that is
below the international space station
and most satellites
even though known potential threats are
monitored by scientists at all times
the problem is that most asteroids are
rather dark objects
whose dimensions are quite modest by
space standards which makes them hard to
detect
however an explosion caused by an impact
of a celestial body with a diameter of
just 10 meters
would be tantamount to the atomic
bombing of hiroshima
it may not leave any radioactive waste
but a blast
this powerful would wipe a little town
right off the face of the earth
an asteroid with a diameter measuring 50
meters
that is as big as a modern multi-storey
building would unleash a power of
several dozen kilotons on impact
which would be enough to raise an entire
city almost to the ground
if an asteroid this large were to fall
into an ocean
it would cause a tsunami reaching up to
10 meters
which would drink destruction all the
way it went traveling for hundreds and
thousands of kilometers from the site of
its impact
where this asteroid's diameter to
measure a kilometer or so
it would cause mass destruction
throughout an entire continent
the force of the explosion on impact
could reach as much as thousands of
megatons and tnt equivalent
and its consequences would haunt the
planet for many years to come
it is highly likely that the human
civilization would not survive a
calamity of this scale
nor would other living creatures with
the only exception of protozoans and
exceptionally enduring organisms
mass extinction events did take place in
the history of our earth
the most notorious of them cretaceous
tertiary extinction event
about 66 million years ago it is posited
that dinosaurs and a number of other
species died out as a result of it
as for the most large-scale mass
extinction event it took place
approximately 251 million years ago
coming in between the permian and the
triassic periods
based on results of paleontological
diggings it was estimated that about 90
percent of
sea species and 70 percent land species
died out as a result
one of the things that caused both of
these dramatic calamities
is believed to be the fall of a large
asteroid
today the number of potentially
dangerous objects is estimated to be in
the region of one and a half to two
thousand
although this number may reach four to
six thousand according to the data
provided by the wise telescope
since they're so small and dark these
celestial objects are rather hard to
spot
for example the size of the asteroid
dubbed 2008 dc3
which burned up in the atmosphere just
above sudan in 2008
was anything from 2 to 5 meters it was
spotted just 20 hours before it would
have impacted the earth
fortunately nobody was hurt there is a
special rating scale known as the
palermo scale
it is a generalized scale reflecting
potential impact risk
posed by this or that celestial body
which takes into account the body's
kinetic energy
and the probability of hitting the earth
the higher the value the bigger the
threat to our planet
if a body's palermo scale value is below
-2
this body is practically safe asteroids
with values between -2 and 0 do not pose
any immediate threat
but require monitoring at all times as
for objects with a value above
zero they are realistically dangerous
for the earth
at this point there isn't a single
celestial object out there with a
positive palermo scale value
and there are only two asteroids in the
yellow alert zone
that is their value is between -2 and 0.
both of them fall into the category of
the apollo asteroids
celestial bodies whose perihelion lies
closer to the sun than the earth's
aphelion
and whose orbital semi-major axis is
bigger than that of the earth
thus these objects cross our planet's
orbit from the outside
the bennu asteroid designation 1999
rq36 with a potential hazard index value
minus
1.69 poses a smaller threat to the two
in the year 2135 it will find itself
just 300 000 kilometers away from the
earth
which is slightly closer to us than the
moon bennu's average diameter measures
approximately 500 meters
and the asteroid's mass is anything
between 60 to 78 million tons
if it were to collide with our earth the
resulting explosion would be tantamount
to about a thousand megatons and tnt
equivalent
which would almost certainly cause major
catastrophic disasters
all over the planet in 2016
nasa launched the osiris-rex probe to
bennu in order to obtain samples of the
minerals making up the asteroid
the probe is scheduled to get back to
the earth in 2023
the more hazardous of the two asteroids
is 1950 d a
with a palomo scale value minus 1.42
today it has the highest probability of
hitting our earth
its diameter measures about 1.3
kilometers
and its mass can be anything from 2 to 4
billion tons
1950 da's orbit is elongated and
elliptical
and it crosses the orbits of our earth
and mars 1950 da's closest approach to
the earth is expected in 2035
but a hazardous approach will take place
only as late as on the 16th of march
what would await us if the asteroid did
impact the earth
let's assume no preventive measures have
been successful to deflect this body
and the disaster is inevitable
an enormous chunk of rock with a
diameter almost
one and a half kilometers and a mass
that could be two to four billion tons
heading towards the earth at a speed of
about 14 kilometers per second
this would be the speed of 1950 da at
the moment it hit the earth
if an impact event did occur as
estimated by nasa
of course part of the matter making up
1950 da would burn up and disperse in
the atmosphere as the asteroid slowed
down
and the main body would be likely to
break up into several large rocks and a
great number of small
bits depending on their size each of
them would cause an explosion of not
less than 20 kilotons on impact for the
earth's crust
that's the average power of a modern
nuclear bomb with a comparatively modest
charge the overall power of the
explosions would most likely be over one
and a half thousand megatons
with a bombarded area larger than that
of europe
all constructions within the radius of
300 to 500 kilometers would be raised to
the ground
and even reinforced underground bunkers
wouldn't guarantee enough safety
the energy of the shock wave would allow
it to sweep around the earth several
times while gradually slowing down
and bringing more destruction on its way
with every lap
if the asteroid were to fall into an
ocean a giant
tsunami would rise 40 meters or higher
tsunamis normally travel for thousands
of kilometers
and as they go their destructive forces
practically don't diminish
therefore coastal areas of the
continents lying near the site of the
impact would be submerged in water
with cities and villages effectively
wiped out
multiple impacts of bits of rock would
raise tons of dust in the atmosphere
winds would scatter these dense clouds
all over the sky
and most sunlight would not reach the
planet which would cause a sharp
temperature fall
this phenomenon is known as nuclear
winter
it is highly probable that an impact of
this scale would affect not only the
crust
but the mantle as well the shock wave
would wake up volcanoes
and they would erupt all over the planet
which in its turn would cause
the second wave of tsunamis and
earthquakes
tons of ash released in the atmosphere
would contribute to further temperature
drops
there is quite a popular belief that
after an asteroid hit the earth it would
affect its orbit or orbital period
this would lead to dramatic climate
changes and even render the planets
completely incapable of sustaining life
however according to some estimates an
impact of even the biggest
asteroid in the solar system would not
be enough to do so
an object realistically able to
noticeably change the earth's orbit
should be as big as the moon or pluto at
the very least
be it as it may if it were to happen the
consequences of an impact of this scale
would be much graver than just a change
of orbit or orbital period
the potential impact risk of 1950 das
hitting our earth is just
0.012 there is no room for complacency
though as the impact probability may
rise
following a change of the asteroids
orbit as a result of collisions with
other celestial objects that may well
take place
for a long while it was believed that
the humanity hadn't advanced enough to
prevent any hazards of asteroid falls
all we could do was just observe
potentially hazardous objects
actually doing something about them like
destroying an asteroid or changing its
orbit was confined to science fiction
films and books
however science doesn't stand still even
in 2004 when a threat posed by apophis
was considered grave enough
it was proposed to cover its surface
with light reflecting film
this way sunlight pressure would change
the asteroid's orbit
other suggestions included nuclear
bombings as well as special power
thrusters powerful enough to shift
orbits of celestial bodies
[Music]
in 2018 nasa in collaboration with
spacex approved the dart program
whose aim is to deflect the asteroid's
trajectory by making it collide with an
artificial spacecraft
the binary near-earth asteroid didymos
made up of two components with diameters
measuring 800 and 150 meters is the
target for the dart demonstration
the launch of the spacecraft is planned
for 2021.
celestial bodies and the solar system
may be closely monitored but there is
always a risk of somebody previously
unknown to us
arriving from the galaxy's outskirts and
heading towards the earth
orbital periods of some comets and
asteroids around the earth may last
hundreds and even thousands of years and
their small sizes and dark surfaces
render these potentially dangerous
visitors barely detectable
still the odds of such a disaster as an
impact event are extremely small
and in fact there are many more dangers
that may befall the human race
on our own planet
pluto is the largest transneptunian
object in the solar system
it is also the largest object in the
kuiper belt
just like most bodies in that region of
space pluto is mostly made up of rock
and dice
and its mass is relatively small
approximately 0.22 percent that of the
earth
just to get a slightly broader picture
let's compare pluto with the moon
pluto's mass is about six times smaller
and its volume is about three times
smaller pluto's total area is 17.7
million square kilometers
and we're briefly back to earth again to
compare it with the area of russia
the largest country in the world which
is slightly smaller
17.1 million square kilometers
as for pluto's diameter it reaches
2376.6 kilometers
which is 1097.6 kilometers less than
that of the moon
as for pluto's atmosphere it is for the
most part comprised of gases evaporating
from the ice on its surface
today we know that its chief component
is nitrogen
apart from that two other gases are
methane and carbon monoxide
under the influence of high-energy
cosmic radiation
other more complex compounds form from
these elements
on account of pluto's surface
temperature these compounds are not
volatile
ethane ethylene and acetylene there are
also the so-called tholins
on settling on the dwarf planet's
surface they have a peculiar property of
giving it a brownish hue
the average surface temperature on pluto
is 50 kelvin
that is 223.15 degrees celsius below
zero with every kilometer higher up
this indicator increases by
approximately seven degrees
and so the atmospheric temperature is 40
degrees
higher than that on the surface this
could be accounted for by the greenhouse
effect
caused by methane
we're used to thinking that pluto's
orbit is stable and
unwavering however on closer observation
it transpired that pluto's movement is
rather chaotic
and can be defined in non-linear
equations
it takes a lot of observation to be able
to detect that
when carried out in short time spans
observations reveal seemingly regular
movement
in reality pluto's orbit slightly shifts
in every period eventually changes to
such a point that it is impossible to
retrace its initial
trajectory this dwarf's planet's
rotation is quite peculiar too
namely it is retrograde which is also
the case for both venus
and uranus it means that they rotate in
the direction
opposite to that of the other planets
around the sun
a day on pluto lasts 6.4 earth days
due to its remoteness and small mass
pluto is a rather challenging celestial
object to study
even very big telescopes show it to us
is a tiny spot
seemingly not much different from a
regular star
we have been able to acquire a certain
amount of data with the help of the
hubble space telescope
nevertheless the greatest and most
important portion of information was
made available
after the launch of the new horizons
mission
the first photo of pluto was made back
in september 2006
when the space probe was testing its
lori camera
as the spacecraft approached pluto
closer and closer
more and more features of this dwarf
planet were revealed to us
thus the object's surface was seen to be
far from homogeneous
albedo that is diffuse reflection
properties of the surface
varies from ten to seventy percent
depending on the area of the object
which makes pluto the second object in
the solar system
after arriapatis in terms of contrast in
albedo
this diversity causes periodic
variations in pluto's luminosity and
spectre as it rotates
the dwarf planet's interior must be made
up of 50 to 70 percent
of rock and 30 to 50 percent of ice
its dense rocky core must be embedded in
an icy mantle
about 300 kilometers thick
according to spectral data there is
water ice on pluto's surface
as well but it is mostly camouflaged by
a layer of more volatile ices
there is also frozen methane and carbon
monoxide
as well as traces of other compounds
generally forming with methane and
nitrogen
when exposed to powerful radiation
in particular these are rethane nitriles
and phthalins which make pluto look
brownish
on the fifteenth of july 2015 the new
horizons space probe
flew by pluto 12 and a half thousand
kilometers away from its surface
both sides of the dwarf planet were
photographed during the flyby
the one to be seen on closest approach
and the opposite one
thanks to these images a vast
heart-shaped area measuring eighteen
hundred by fifteen hundred kilometers
was identified
it was later nicknamed pluto's heart or
tombow regio
the left part of this area is believed
to be a crater filled with crystal
nitrogen
also two mountain ranges were identified
in this area
the height of the first reaches 3500
meters
and it was given the name the tensing
montes
the height of the second one dubbed the
hillary montes
reaches up to 1500 meters
the most notable geological object found
on pluto
is sputnik planitia this trench is
likely to be an impact crater with a
diameter measuring 1492 kilometers
sputnik planitia is filled with frozen
gases
and is streaked with a great number of
grooves which divided into irregular
cell-like areas measuring dozens of
kilometers
there may also be cryovolcanism on pluto
the last image taken by the spacecraft
looks to be indicative of just that
the potential cryo volcano that can be
seen in this picture
was dubbed right mons the surface in the
picture is comparatively young by space
standards
and practically devoid of impact craters
this
shows that the crust in this area was
formed relatively recently
and if right mons really is a cryo
volcano
its enormous size of 144 kilometers
across and four kilometers high
easily makes it the largest cryovolcano
in the outer area of the solar system
among other interesting features
discovered by new horizons
there is a blue stratified haze
enveloping the whole of the dwarf planet
in the images the haze is seen to reach
over 200 kilometers high
and is registered by the ultraviolet
spectrometer to persist to the point of
300 kilometers above the surface
the haze is likely to be made up of
particles of non-volatile elements that
originate from atmospheric gases
the ones i've already spoken about these
elements gradually settle on the dwarf
planet's surface
and that is the way this effect is
produced
the new horizons mission is scheduled to
continue until
2026 apart from studying the objects in
the pluto system
the spacecraft has already provided
insights into other kuiper belt objects
too
and even though its fuel supply is
insufficient for a dramatic change of
course
the radioisotope generator's energy
should be enough to last it for another
10 years
immediately after the space probe had
flown by pluto
astronomers used the hubble telescope to
look around for other objects that could
be observed within the framework of the
mission
the first of them ultimatuly is a binary
asteroid in the kuiper belt
whose two components diameters measure
19 and 14 kilometers
it was closely passed by new horizons on
the 1st of january 2019
another object was the asteroid 2014
pn70 measuring 40 kilometers across
it was passed by the probe in march 2019
excitingly apart from that having
traveled 8 billion kilometers away from
the earth
new horizons reached a great vantage
point for better observation of the
stars closest to the sun
proxima centauri and wolf 359
in april 2020 the spacecraft was also
used for double checking the distance to
these stars
apart from the objectives mentioned this
amazing mission
stands a good chance of being able to
reach quite a few more in the future
while the spacecraft keeps beaming back
new images to the earth
we will be able to conduct research
based on the photos of the celestial
bodies it has already passed
for example the pictures of pluto's
largest moon
charon taken on their brief encounter
with a space probe
several centuries ago it was quite
unimaginable to admit of discovering
exoplanets
however everything changed in 1992 as
the polish astronomer alexander
washington was studying the pulsar
psr-1257 plus 12
it was noticed that its pulsation period
was irregular
which was accounted for by the influence
of two planets with a mass
four times that of our earth this
hypothesis was later confirmed
which led to the conclusion that the
first planetary system beyond ours
had been discovered there are three
objects in that system
two of which have a mass similar to that
of the earth and are comparatively close
to their pulsar in the constellation
virgo
due to the fact that it is rather remote
from us and the conditions for
sustaining life are poor
the psr1257 plus 12
system is of little interest to
scientists although its discovery led us
to believe
that the search for earth-like worlds
may eventually be a success
just three years later the first
exoplanet orbiting a sun-like star was
discovered
50 light years away from the earth and
was dubbed 51 pegasi b
just several years later the number of
confirmed exoplanets counted dozens
and today 4173 exoplanets
in 3096 different planetary systems
unknown to science in addition a great
number of earth-like objects
is still awaiting the confirmation of
their status
which is possible after a secondary
registration with telescopes on earth
the number of celestial objects of this
kind in the entire milky way
may well be over a hundred billion with
about one-fifth of them
bearing resemblance to our earth
interestingly
most of the discovered earth-like
exoplanets
are located not very far from our system
ros128b this planet was discovered in
2017 by european scientists with the
help of the high accuracy radial
velocity planet searcher
or halves at the observatory in chile
the object is located in the single star
system
ros 128 which is the 13th closest star
to us
the object is a faint red dwarf with a
mass of 0.15 that of the sun
it was possible to discover this planet
thanks to its gravity
which leads to minor variations of the
stellar spectrum of its parent star
while observing these variations harps
is able to spot planets around stars
in this particular case it took the
telescope approximately 10 years to
collect sufficient data
before discovering this planet this
effort paid off
ros-128b became the second earth-like
exoplanet
lying closest to us it is located 11
light years away from the earth
in the constellation virgo apart from
that
astronomers claim it to be the most
moderate of all known exoplanets
due to its mass its temperature and its
rather calm parent star
it takes this planet 10 days to orbit
its star
it finds itself in the habitable zone
since the temperature
of the photosphere and luminosity of ros
are low it is also classified as an
earth-like
type of planet and at the moment ros128b
is one of the most likely candidates to
be a potentially habitable exoplanet
besides research done in 2018 confirmed
that its climate is favorable enough to
sustain life
another exoplanet on the list of
earth-like objects located closest to us
is glieser 667cc
this celestial body is part of the
triple star stellar system
glieser 667 in the constellation
scorpius
it consists of two orange dwarves and
one red dwarf
the first two components a and b lie
12.6 astronomical units from each other
with the third component orbiting them
at a distance of 230 astronomical units
the earth-like planet in this system was
discovered on november the 29th
2011 in the geneva observatory with the
help of the doppler method
the object is 22.7 light years away from
the earth
and is the second exoplanet orbiting its
host
star the mass of gliese 667cc
is about 3.8 times that of the earth
while its temperature range may be
rather similar to the terrestrial one
modeling at the planetary habitability
laboratory
managed by university of puerto rico
reveals
that the average surface temperature of
the atmosphere of gliese 667cc
must be approximately 27 degrees celsius
the planet receives about 90 percent of
energy
compared to that received by the earth
from the sun
also gliese 667cc is almost
certain to be locked in its orbit that
is it faces its star with one on the
same side
if the planet's orbit does not curve too
little and if its mass is not too big
the greenhouse effect produced by the
rather dense atmosphere
must be quite sufficient to create
favorable conditions
for primitive life forms
[Music]
the next deserving object in our list is
hd855
an exoplanet orbiting the orange dwarf
hd-85512
in the constellation velar its star
is a single k-type main sequence star
with the mass 0.69 that of our sun
as for its age it is more than 5.6
billion years old
the exoplanet discovered close to it
is located 36 light years away from the
earth
and its mass is 3.6 times that of our
planet
at the same time hd 85512b
be one of the smallest planets in the
habitable zone
it was spotted in august 2011 with a
harps telescope
the supposed steady-state temperature of
its surface
is something around 25 degrees celsius
if the planet's atmosphere is identical
to that of the earth
its surface temperature should reach 78
degrees celsius
it is also highly probable that there is
liquid water
on this celestial body which is why for
some time it was believed to become the
most likely place
where life would be discovered first
apart from the objects mentioned there
is a number of other celestial bodies in
space
located quite close to us which also
boasts
some unique features many of them may
well contain
various life forms and maybe not quite
as far from us
as we would imagine however we should
bear in mind
that some half a century ago man did not
possess a tenth of information known to
us today
and in the future the progress of our
discoveries
is going to escalate even more
dramatically
for example on december the 18th 2019
the k-op space telescope was
successfully launched in orbit by the
european space agency
it is specifically aimed at exploring
exoplanets
using the transit method it may be this
spacecraft is to contribute to the list
of earth-like exoplanets
and it may become the telescope to first
discover
alien life forms in the universe
science does not stand still and every
new day bears witness to the fact that
mankind continues to actively stride
forward
if this progress does not lose its
momentum sooner or later we are bound to
find an answer to the eternal
mind perturbing question are we alone
in the universe and i hope the answer we
get will prove that life is not a mere
accident
but a logical consequence of the
evolution in our universe
as a rule micro quasars are x-ray
binaries
that is stellar systems made up of two
components
one of them is a regular star similar to
our sun
the other component is a compact object
like a black hole or a neutron star
matter in such micro quasars is
constantly in the process of
accumulating in the compact object
which is accompanied by occasional
outflows of matter at great speeds
these outflows are known as jets and the
nature of these jets reminds one of
processes
taking place in regular quasars
now it is not a regular occurrence in
ordinary quasars
meanwhile as the mass of a micro quasar
is smaller than that of an ordinary
quasar
jets may originate here practically on a
daily basis
the principal difference between micro
quasars and ordinary quasars is in their
mass
and the frequency of matter outflows for
example
the mass of the compact components and
micro quasars is considerably smaller
than the mass of those in regular
quasars
it is just several cellular masses just
to compare
the average mass of a supermassive black
hole in the center of a quasar
may be approximately as much as a
hundred million solar masses
as for the mass of the black hole likely
to be found in the center of ss-433
it must be just a few dozen solar masses
the accretion disk of a micro quasar is
intensely luminescent
with emissions in the optical and x-ray
bands
a regular quasar is an astronomical body
boasting the highest luminosity among
other objects
in the observable universe according to
contemporary scientific views
these celestial bodies are active cores
of galaxies where a supermassive black
hole
sucks in matter all around it thus
forming an accretion disk
as for the disk itself it is a source of
very powerful luminosity
just to give you an idea its luminosity
may sometimes be hundreds of times as
intense as that of all stars in a galaxy
like
ours combined to date
over 200 000 quasars have been
identified
we're able to observe some of these
quasars in the sky
even without using a telescope and so
the rate of discovering new objects of
one or the other category is another
principal parameter
by which regular quasars and micro
quasars differ
if we look at the list of known micro
quasars it contains
just a few entries so far the first
micro quasar was discovered back in 1978
when a source of unusual radio and x-ray
emissions was detected by two
astronomers from the university of
cambridge
as they were looking for debris left
over from supernovae
detected in the constellation aquila
this source was later dubbed
ss433
the object under scrutiny is an
eclipsing x-ray binary system
one of its components is likely to be a
black hole
as for the second component it is a star
of spectral type a
that is a main sequence dwarf star of a
whitish hue
it is assumed that this star's mass is
10 to 30 times that of our sun
and more likely than not the dwarf used
to be considerably heavier in the
earlier stages of its existence
its surface temperature is thought to be
anything from 7000 to eleven and a half
thousand degrees kelvin this temperature
range is typical for stars of this type
it is actually its temperature that
gives the star its pale yellow tint
in fact if we look at the stars closest
to the sun
then sirius altair and viga fall into
the same class as this star
ss-433 is located within the supernova
remnant
w-50 sometimes also called the manatee
nebula
the age of this nebula is estimated at
approximately 20
000 years and the distance between the
nebula and the earth measures about 18
000 light years the jets from ss-433
distort the clouds surrounding the w-50
nebula
according to a certain theory the w-50
nebula and the micro quasar
ss-433 are actually related
and came to be as a result of one in the
same supernova event
which supposedly took place around 20
000 years ago
it takes either of the two objects in
the system 13.1 days to orbit the common
mass center
in fact the way the ss-433 system works
is quite exciting with both components
constantly interacting with each other
matter from the second component that is
the regular star
flows to the first component or the
primary supposedly a black hole
thus forming an accretion disk around it
as it spirals
the matter heats up to extreme
temperatures and emits x-rays
some part of the smatter leaves the
system in two jets
at the rate of approximately 26 of the
speed of light
that is 79 000 kilometers per second
in 2019 thanks to the alma observatory
astronomers managed to get detailed
images of ss-433
it was clear from the emission structure
that the micro quasars jets themselves
are rather narrow
and their shape is irregular and has
nodes
further studies of the object showed
that the shape of the jets is distorted
as a result of precession
that is a process when the jets slowly
rotate on their axis as they spiral
the diameter of either of the two jets
ejected from the micro quasar in two
opposite directions
measures approximately 5 000 times the
diameter of the solar system
as ss-433 is relatively close to the
earth it is particularly valuable to
scientists studying the phenomenon of
micro quasars
images beamed back by the alma
observatory showed its jets for the
first time
and it also helped establish the
direction these jets point out is never
the same
just like a top the spinning toy
gradually slows down
they too rotate on their axis which is
perpendicular to the plane of the
accretion disk
the armor images boasted another
outstanding feature
the shape of ss-433 was predicted in
fine detail thanks to spectroscopic
measurements that had been done in 2018
using the global jet watch telescopes
and so the actual shape largely
corresponds to the new images
where ss433 is really seen to have a
shape reminding one of a corkscrew
it isn't a rare occasion when jets like
that originate here or there in the
universe
as a rule jets of plasma also known as
relativistic jets
are spewed out of the centers of active
galaxies quasars and radio galaxies
when this occurs there are usually two
jets as such
pointing in the opposite directions and
this is exactly what we can observe in
the case of ss433
today the phenomenon of jets like that
wants deeper studying
it is believed that jets originate
following the interaction between
magnetic fields and the accretion disk
around a black hole or a neutron star
as for their size it may be staggeringly
enormous
in the case of the radio galaxy 3c one
two zero for example
the jet stretches for at least several
kilo pass
away from its source it is highly
probable that in the future the regular
star in the ss433
system will shed its outer layer
completely as a result of the influence
of the compact object
its core meanwhile will remain hot and
thus
the star will qualify to be called a hot
sub dwarf
later the star is to be gradually sucked
in by the black hole
and sooner or later after this process
is completed
the ss433 system will assume a classical
look
it will comprise just the compact object
the process of this system's evolution
will of course continue for thousands of
years
so we have plenty of time to study this
phenomenon
and while the micro quasar ss-433 is
active
we will have many opportunities to carry
out detailed observation
that would help us understand the nature
of this celestial object
let's keep in touch
predictably enough the term
intergalactic space is generally used to
refer to parts of space between galaxies
it is believed that certain portions of
these areas are practically devoid of
any matter
which makes their composition quite
close to that of absolute vacuum
with some of its areas stretching as far
as millions of light years in all
directions
intergalactic space is for the most part
filled with ionized gas
generally this gas is hot hydrogen whose
density here
is 10 times less than that in
interstellar environment
namely less than one atom to one cubic
decimeter
there are also heavier elements to be
found here as well
like carbon oxygen and silicon
some part of intergalactic gas is
concentrated in clouds differing from
each other very much in terms of density
and temperature interestingly the
chemical composition of their gas is
diverse
it may contain atoms of hydrogen helium
carbon nitrogen oxygen sulfur
and various metals it is this gas that
more likely than not
feeds stellar formations in all galaxies
there are also much larger objects to be
found in intergalactic space
for example stars were spotted there
quite recently
the total number of intergalactic stars
in the observable universe may reach
several trillion within the milky way
alone
around 650 of these rogue stars have
been pinpointed so far
as a rule intergalactic mata doesn't
emit any light
and is mostly invisible to the potential
observer that is why
its discovery was actually made by pure
chance
it all started with quasars which were
discovered in the 1960s
very soon scientists noticed that the
light from the quasars had
certain missing pieces in some spectra
these particles were absorbed by
something in between quasars and
astronomers telescopes
it later transpired that this invisible
matter was the gas of the intergalactic
medium
the igm in the decades that followed
vast accumulations and filaments of gas
and heavier elements were discovered in
intergalactic space
and even though at first glance it
appears to be empty
its dimensions are so mind-blowing that
there must be more matter
evenly distributed around it than there
is mata in all the galaxies of the
observable universe combined
it is safe to assume that some part of
intergalactic gas has been left out
there after the hypothetical big bang
still as there are heavier elements in
its composition it may only mean that
many of these elements used to be part
of interstellar dust
lost by other galaxies
intergalactic gas actually plays an
important role in the process of the
universe's evolution
under the influence of a galaxy's
gravitational pull
gas is gradually sucked into galaxies at
the rate of one
solar mass a year which is quite close
to the rate of star formation in the
disk of the milky way
apart from that matter exchange among
all galaxies
occurs thanks to this process the point
is that stars in a given area of the
universe collapse and release
part of their matter in intergalactic
space
having been released the mata becomes
part of intergalactic gas
and so later takes part in the processes
of star formation in other galaxies
consequently star formation in galaxies
will not stop
while there is still intergalactic gas
around pulled by gravity
substantial portion of intergalactic gas
is matter remaining after supernovae
which is why temperatures in some areas
of intergalactic environments are
extremely high
sometimes reaching as much as several
million degrees celsius
the high temperature of some areas may
also be accounted for by electromagnetic
radiation
emitted by intergalactic black holes
following mata accretion on their
surfaces
or else by powerful streams of energy
emitted by still more massive black
holes
intergalactic gas plays the role of raw
material in star formation
while intergalactic space is some sort
of a tank used for its storage
the mechanism of intergalactic gas
recirculation
hasn't been studied deeply enough first
of all because unlike galaxies which are
bright and easily seen
this gas emits no light to speak of
in their attempt to study this
phenomenon astronomers have devised
supercomputer foggy foggy modelled the
patterns of intergalactic gas movements
and it is possible to observe how gas
traveled around galaxies in the course
of 13 billion years
most of this matter is carried to
intergalactic environment by stellar
wind
that is thanks to the process of mata
flow from stars to areas beyond their
galaxies
it should be mentioned that this occurs
when particles in a star's atmosphere
accelerate to speeds exceeding the
escape velocity of this star
stellar wind is crucial for stellar
evolution
as a result of this process the mass of
a star diminishes
and the intensity of this process has a
direct impact on this particular star's
lifespan
also stellar wind is capable of carrying
mata enormous distances through space
away from its departure point as it were
moreover
it may have an impact on matter around
it by sharing some of its kinetic energy
results of this process may be clearly
observed in the shapes of some galaxies
or nebulae for instance the emission
nebula
ngc 7635 nicknamed bubble
assumed its shape as a result of this
process
and in the case of galaxy m82 also known
as the cigar galaxy
we can observe how stellar wind from a
great number of stars caused clearly
seen matter rejections from the galaxy
[Music]
apart from the debris left over from
supernovae there is also intergalactic
dust to be found in this environment
today it is posited that it is
intergalactic dust that is to blame for
jinxing estimations of distances on the
intergalactic scale
for example when supernovae quasars or
other galaxies are being observed
among its many properties it is capable
of forming clouds
by 1980 four such nebulae had been
pinpointed within several megapass sects
from the milky way
as for intergalactic stars they are
rather difficult to detect and explore
some of them have been spotted in the
x-ray spectrum with the help of the
chandra x-ray observatory
many of them are binary systems made up
of one regular star as one component
and one compact heavy object like a
black hole is the other
when such celestial bodies lie close to
each other
the more massive component attracts
matter from the regular star
while flowing to its new host mata
spirals away from its source to form an
accretion disk
this disk compresses and heats up to
extremely high temperatures
and as a result it does not simply
become luminescent
but starts emitting x-rays it is next to
impossible to spot most objects of this
kind
using regular telescopes meanwhile
rogue stars inhabiting voids may
eventually prove to be quite a common
thing
rather than something extraordinary and
perhaps about half of starlight is
actually emitted by stars lying beyond
the boundaries of galaxies
it is hard to tell how big their number
may be
and today it is barely possible to
imagine that man will ever visit those
places
objects lurking in those mysterious
parts of space
may be of considerable interest to
science
and who knows perhaps it is
intergalactic space that will be scanned
with all
telescopes by scientists in a few
centuries time
still for now this environment is just
another mystery of the universe
quite beyond our reach at this point it
is places like this that really thwart
our ambition to completely figure out
space
and its properties and it is places like
this that drive us to take
keen interest in how it all works
the earliest theory of the genesis of
our world is what is known as theory of
the stationary universe
or steady-state universe supporters of
this theory claim that the universe has
no beginning and no end
it has always been and always will be in
its steady state of equilibrium
however very soon scientific estimations
prove this theory likely to be wrong
as there are some irreversible processes
taking place in the universe
in the 1910s and 1920s the big bang
theory was formulated and widely
popularized
today it is one of the most consistent
scientific theories
and it is able to account for the
universe's genesis and evolution
dozens of scientists contributed to the
development of the big bang theory
and albert einstein's works on the
general theory of relativity
laid the theories foundation the main
conclusion this theory enabled
scientists to arrive at
is the supposition that the fate of the
universe depends on dark energy
a theoretical type of energy causing
space to expand
be it as it may at this point it is
quite impossible to say anything
definite about this physical phenomenon
there are a great number of theories
about this and each of them has its
praiseworthy aspects and shortcomings
according to data we possess today the
age of the universe is calculated from
the moment of the big bang
and is estimated at slightly less than
14 billion years
the universe is constantly expanding and
depending on the density of dark energy
it will either expand
forever at a regularly increasing rate
or else the expansion will slow down and
reverse
in this case the universe is bound to
compress into an infinitely small
singularity
similar to what it originated from today
science is not ready to give a definite
answer to the question
which of these two possibilities will
prevail however it is ready to suggest
at least
two equally possible scenarios of what
may happen next
referred to as the big rip and the big
crunch
the universe's expansion rate is
proportional to distances between
objects the further some objects are
located from each other
the higher the expansion rate imagine a
balloon pumped with air
there are two dots on it if we pump
still more air into the balloon
the dots will get further away from each
other
that's the way the expansion of the
universe works it is space itself that
expands
the further the dots are initially
located the faster they get still
further apart
at a certain point this rate exceeds the
speed of light
this point is known as the event horizon
all objects beyond it disappear from
view and they drift away beyond the
reach of the most advanced telescopes
never to be observed again
just imagine first the remotest galaxies
and clusters will disappear from the sky
then one by one the milky way stars will
fade away
and to crown it all it will be the turn
for our sun
to go dim what a gloomy sight
if the big rip theory holds good the
universe's expansion rate will be
constantly on the increase
this will lead to expansion forces
gradually overcoming gravity forces
following that first galaxy clusters and
then galaxies
themselves and star clusters will be
broken up
after that it will be the turn for
stellar systems to disintegrate
as host stars will not have sufficient
pool to keep their planets and
satellites from floating away
at the next stage matter will be reduced
to atoms and these will be reduced to
subatomic particles
matter will effectively cease to exist
after this physical laws as we know them
will cease to be
and any further developments are quite
impossible to predict
observations today show that space
expands
and the expansion rate is on the
increase however we're not familiar with
the nature of dark energy
it may well have properties unknown to
us at this point
and these may reverse the expansion
processes
as a result the universe will start
contracting
this may well happen if general
gravitation created by all matter in the
universe
exceeds its expansion force this
scenario is what is known as the big
crunch
in this case processes in the universe
will run in the same manner until its
size decreases five times
galaxy clusters will come together as
one supercluster
which in essence will fill the entire
universe considerably shrunk by this
point
meanwhile inside the galaxies events
like births and deaths of stars
planet formation and so on will keep
taking place
just like before when the universe
contracts 20 times more
its volume will account for just one
percent of that of today's
and all galaxies will blend into one the
relic radiation temperature by that time
will measure
274 degrees kelvin and it will still
continue to grow
this means that there won't be any
liquid water left in the universe
and water is vital for biological life
as we know it
further contraction of space will cause
the universe to heat up even more
planets will first be burnt and then
melted
all matter will crumple into an enormous
cloud of boiling plasma
after that atoms and subatomic particles
will disperse
and eventually the universe will
collapse into a singularity similar to
the one it used to be when it was born
there is a theory which is a kind of a
spin-off of the big crunch theory
it is known as the big bounce theory
according to the big balance theory
on reaching the state of singularity
following the big crunch
the universe will be reborn as a result
of yet another big bang
and the cycle will repeat itself again
and again supposedly forever
as far as it is possible to speak about
eternity and conditions devoid of time
and space i will repeat myself
yet again by saying that our knowledge
about dark is too meager to speak about
the duration
of any of these scenarios for all we
know
the next big rip or big crunch for that
matter will take place in a period when
there are still stars and planets around
but what if it isn't the case what will
happen to the universe
if its ultimate fate is still extremely
remote in time
still the laws of physics imply that the
universe as we more or less know it
cannot exist forever there are four
clearly defined
epochs in cosmology and each of them is
associated with this or that particular
phenomenon
we live in the so-called stelliferous
era
there is a lot of interstellar gas in
the parts of the universe around us
it is used as raw material for stars to
form from
and used stars are born from this gas
and the process will continue
until all interstellar gas has been
depleted
this epoch is expected to be over in the
period from 1 to 100 trillion years from
now
by that time the sun and the
overwhelming majority of other stars
will have depleted their nuclear fuel
subsequently turning into white dwarfs
neutron stars or black
holes i've actually already spoken about
it in an earlier video
the next era is known as the degenerate
era
there will not be any main sequence
stars around anymore
most mata in the universe will remain in
the form of white and brown dwarves and
some mata will persist as neutron stars
and black holes
it will take a great amount of time for
all these objects to cool off
around a duodecillion or 10 to the power
of 39 years
white dwarves will gradually give off
their heat in the form of radiation
and become black dwarves as for brown
dwarves they will cool off too
reactions taking place in their interior
at a sluggish rate
will eventually stop completely
gradually most matter will be slurped by
black holes
at this stage of the universe's
evolution dark matter annihilation and
protons disintegration will be the major
processes
the proton is a subatomic particle that
atoms known to science are built of
it is considered one of the most durable
subatomic particles
its life expectancy as it were accounts
for approximately 100 geodesian
or 10 to the power of 41 years
now by the time this sierra comes to an
end mata in the universe will look like
a great ocean of freely floating
elementary particles with an occasional
neutron star or black hole tucked away
among them
the next era is the black hole era
according to some theories black holes
will form clusters and eventually blend
together
thus forming one single gargantuan black
hole
alternative theories suggest that black
holes will slowly evaporate while
emitting energy before vanishing
completely
black hole evaporation is a quantum
effect produced by what is known as
hawking radiation
the smaller hole the more intense of its
evaporation
which eventually strips the whole of all
its matter and energy
this process is supposed to persist for
10 to the power of 100 years
this number is also referred to as
google
be it as it may eventually only dead
expanses of space will be left in the
universe
this space will contain debris left over
from processes having taken place in the
previous sea parks
photons electrons positrons neutrinos
and quarks
electrons and positrons will collide
thus causing annihilation
the universe may exist in this state
practically forever
until the next big crunch or big rip at
the very least
either way the humanity will be long
gone at that time
its existence is likely to be terminated
in the stelliferous era
our planet meanwhile will remain
habitable for another billion years or
so
and after that it will be burned by the
ever-intensifying glow of the sun
about five or six billion years later
our sun
by then a red giant will shed its outer
layers and become a white dwarf
but what will happen after the universe
dies
disappointing as it is there is
absolutely no way we can answer this
question
the trouble is whatever the scenario
there won't be either time or space as
we know them
even if the big bounce theory or the big
crunch theory is right
or else a new big bang takes place thus
giving birth to a new universe
with a fresh set of galaxies and stars
we will simply never
find out just like we will never find
out what it used to be like in the
universe
before hours because the word must be
heard in silence there must be darkness
to see the stars
it goes without saying that what we've
just seen is an infinitely tiny portion
of fascinating things out there we could
have looked at in this film
their number is infinite and it's going
to take scientists
centuries on end to describe the nature
of each of them
but even objects we already know of
today can be baffling to many scientists
yet with information about them
regularly updated
we will definitely have something
exciting to share with you
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you